à noite eu fiquei à frente da secretaria
municipal de educação de salvador por
500 dias último dia não foi tão lembrado
quanto o primeiro
eu me lembro claramente na primeira
visita que fiz uma escola de salvador
quando a professora dentro da sala de
aula aguardava a minha presença para não
apertar a minha mão
fui cumprimentá la ela pediu desculpas
de maneira muito delicada falou o
secretário
eu peço licença para não te cumprimentar
eu sou da resistência
eu falei pois não pensou da insistência
e ali começava uma relação de um novo
secretário com a rede de 15 mil pessoas
de mais de 400 escolas na rede
absolutamente fragmentada repartida é
que de um lado a secretaria tentava em
por projetos ou ela baixa de cada escola
decididos na frieza dos ar condicionado
dos gabinetes dos secretários e do outro
lado a escola isolada e reparte bamba
existia uma vida autônoma como se ela
não viver sua própria rede
o desafio que enfrentei com o secretário
não foi diminuir as goteiras da escola
não foi ampliar as vagas da educação
infantil
o desafio foi já era um melhor resultado
pedagoga
o desafio foi criar conexões com a rede
conectada ea gente pode ver claramente
que existe ali eram dois lados
a secretaria e as escolas em que um lado
se achava certo e outro lado se achava
errado
a minha percepção foi muito claro o que
falou hoje a mensagem que trago é que
não existe certo não existe errado
sequer pode existir dois lados um certo
eo certo esses são os dois lados
possíveis escolhe cinco caminhos para
atravessar esse desafio
o primeiro caminho estabelecido na
premissa de que ninguém estava certo
ninguém estava errado que cada um na sua
realidade na sua história de vida nas
suas dificuldades nas suas
possibilidades de superação
cada um tinha sua certeza que cada um
tinha seus equívocos
estabelecemos depois da premissa um
segundo caminho regras
precisávamos conversar muito mas essa
conversa prova será objetiva com clareza
e crueldade lealdade não significa
necessariamente concordar com tudo
sequer concordar com muito mas a
lealdade significa dizer que não
concordava e não levar pra casa engolido
elementos sem dizer o outro sem olhar no
olho sem pegar na mão e dizer o que nós
podíamos conjuntamente fazer para
melhorar aquela rede que apresentava dos
piores resultados pedagógicos do brasil
um terceiro caminhão estabelecemos as
ações possíveis que cada um em dia na
sua individualidade que todos entendiam
no seu conjunto com necessárias e comuns
para transformar a realidade da rede
municipal de educação de salvador
estabelecendo 112 ações que todos todos
que estavam nas reuniões representando
coordenadores pedagógicos professores
diretores de escola e membros de paz
todos entendiam que eram 112 ações
necessárias e possíveis e criamos assim
o programa combinado 112 ações para
melhorar a escola de salvador
o quarto que a linha foi entender que as
ações eram as possíveis e não é todas as
desejáveis
era impossível criamos uma rede ideal em
tão pouco tempo
abraçamos com as mãos o que a gente
podia alcançar ea rede das ações
possíveis se tornou a rede da lealdade
da franqueza da transparência e também
do enfrentamento da resistência da
insistência foi assim
nesse quarto caminho que é 112 ações
foram gradativamente sendo superadas ou
abandonadas quando alguém tem dia que
não seria possível cumprir a sua meta
chegava para o outro dizia não vou
conseguir
estou vindo aqui para dizer que não vai
ser possível
isso que é lealdade a percepção de que
não podemos tudo mas perdemos tudo
a indicação da conexão e por fim o
quinto caminho entender que os
resultados obtidos obtidos resultados
divididos compartilhados e
responsabilidade de todos
aquela rede não precisava de um herói e
se ela podia ser o secretário não podia
ser um diretor de escola não podia ser
um pai naquela rede precisava
compartilhar os resultados e conseguimos
reduzir o abandono escolar em 50% de
4600 crianças que abandonam a escola
hoje 2300 abandona a escola ainda muito
muito muito e tem muita coisa pra fazer
reduzir o abandono escolar
ampliamos o acesso à educação infantil
em quase duas vezes
reduzimos a distorção idade-série a
quantidade de crianças que têm que têm
atraso escolar saindo de 40 para 20 9
por cento aumentando o rendimento
escolar em apenas 500 dias
quem fez o quê eu não quem fez o diretor
é quem fez foi o professor quem fez foi
a conexão que tornou isso tudo é
possível
e aí o que a gente aprendeu com isso
primeiro que a nossa crença deve ser
respeitada assim como do outro deve ser
respeitada que nós estamos tão certo
quanto o outro também pode estar certo
que é preciso sobretudo entender que a
crença do outro deve ser tão importante
quanto a sua crença ea certeza que você
está certo é tão absoluta quanto a
certeza que o outro também tem que dar
certo a seguir aprendizado é preciso
ceder as concessões são os atos que
fazem as grandes conquistas no mundo
concessão não é perda da concessão a
vitória conquista reunião é lógico que
as grandes cercas as cercas bem traçadas
e bem construídas casas dos vizinhos não
tenho a menor dúvida disso mas lado de
cd é que vai nos tornar capazes de sair
vencedor de qualquer história entender
que o outro também tem razão e que o
outro também precisa ter seu espaço
o terceiro elemento importante nessa
história é que das conexões
só em resultado que lhe pertencia nem aí
nem aí
o que nós conquistamos na rede municipal
lhe pertencia àquela professora que
resistiu ao aperto de mão do secretário
nem pertencia o secretário o resultado
daquilo tudo é o terceiro elemento que
surgiu novo que veio ao mundo com uma
grande novidade é fruto do que nem eu
pensava em que o outro pensava fruto
daquilo tudo é chamado o terceiro
elemento dessa grande conexão que
fizemos na rede principal quarta coisa
importante
não há a menor graça em fazer conexão
com as próprias tribos
o grande desafio é conquistar o outro é
a outra tribo porque a grande conquista
e pegar quem está do seu outro lado não
quer apertar sua mão ela venha comigo se
apertar minha mão mas vamos tentar
entender por que você não quer apertar
minha mão e porque eu também não fazendo
tanta questão de apertar sul e quando ao
final de 500 dias essas tribos
diferentes se tornou a terceira tribo é
que a gente compreende que a sessão a
conquista um enfrentamento o
tensionamento mas sobretudo um ato
singelo de entender que o outro tem toda
razão quanto a gente é que vai gerar
justamente a grande riqueza quer fazer
uma conexão com alguém de outra tribo
com alguém que tem um pensamento
diferente do nosso
por fim um alerta muito claro as falsas
conexões a compreensão de que estamos
cada vez mais conectados não era em que
o fez e substituiu faça a gente acha que
as conexões estão mais intensas e cada
vez maiores
eu vi uma vez há cerca de cinco anos
atrás pichado no muro na cidade de
coimbra em portugal
a faixa que dizia assim não há nada mais
sexy do que um homem sem facebook
é muito séries desde então decidiram ter
facebook
tudo é questão de autoestima
tem gente que precisa disso eu estava
precisando naquele momento e até hoje
não tem ninguém vira herói do rio porque
o seu instagram foi compartilhado com
100 mil pessoas 50 mil pessoas
e aqui eu me lembro de um diálogo também
nos primeiros dias na secretaria
quando cheguei na porta de uma sala e
uma professora mostrava as crianças que
ela tava curtindo uma página que pedia
mais árvores plantadas na cidade
e aquela página já tinha chegado a 5 mil
curtidas ea criança perguntou à
professora
isso significa que teremos mais cinco
mil árvores na cidade
a professora falou não
naquele momento ela refletiu que aquela
criança ensinava que se dependêssemos as
curtidas no facebook
a quantidade de pessoas que nas redes
sociais se manifesta por mais árvores na
cidade
se cada uma dessas tivesse de fato
contado uma árvore
teríamos aqui na capital da mata
atlântica não tenho uma dúvida portanto
as conexões reais
as conexões verdadeiras as conexões
fomos capazes de fazer na rede municipal
de educação todos nós da rede foram
feitas com o olho no olho com a pele com
um aperto de mão e sem aperto de mão mas
com lealdade com franqueza e com a
compreensão que que estavam ali crianças
que sabem de fato que árvores ou nascem
se forem efetivamente implantadas
muito obrigado